well from yoda to ewok to princess leia
our may the fourth celebration continues
now
at rogue toys rocky stop by to catch up
with a special star wars actress
she'll tell you how you can do the same
you know the force is always strong here
rogue toys and tonight you can celebrate
the right way with julie dolan the voice
of princess leia of rebels
on disney plus but you can also get all
of this
signed you can get swag you can get toys
you can talk you can chat with her i've
been chatting with her
she's so much fun so i want to get into
it okay all right so princess leia the
voice of princess leia yes on rebels but
that wasn't your first go
from the star wars franchise right right
star wars uh star tours the ride at
disneyland and disney
world disney world that was my first job
as leia and dave filoni heard that
and so he brought me in to audition for
rebels that's incredible that's how
hollywood works and i love that
a lot of networking going on you know
yeah you never thought that you were
gonna
have your voice played at disneyland
that's going to outlive
me right now they'll be there for as
long as they have the ride that is
incredible and now disneyland is back
open so there's that
oh yeah that's right that's relevant
okay so let's talk about the rebel show
on disney it's on disney plus you can
watch all the episodes and a lot of the
thing i like about it is a lot of the
young kids are learning about star wars
through star wars rebels now so they're
becoming fans at a young age and i know
their parents love that
yes and our camera guy back there by the
way is a super fan
super star wars fan and he has written a
couple fan questions for you
are you ready for this he wanted to
stump you okay
all right so first we have where was
princess leia born
uh not alderaan uh it was an asteroid uh
paulus masa there we go she got it she
got it lance i'm sorry you didn't stump
her
and then this one might be easy princess
leia's biological father
well it was anakin skywalker who later
became darth vader there we go
all right good job all right so now he
wants to know
will princess leia be making an
appearance in the bad batch which is
another star wars
cartoon well she would be very young so
they might bring in another actress that
sounds like her as a
young or they could audition me and i
could try to sound
very young oh interesting to see okay
well now that you're speaking of the
voice i want to hear a little something
in the princess leia voice and then you
have to cheer her right
general kenobi years ago you served my
father in the clone wars and now he begs
you to help him in his struggle against
the empire
that's all i got oh my god that was
beautiful see
this is why this is why you are princess
leia all right julie thank you so much
for having me oh yes come on guys come
on down
i'll be here i want everybody to see
say hello and uh you got to have a cute
little star wars oh yeah
i'm on bb8 all right 4 to 8 p.m here at
rogue toys you guys in may the 4th
be with me with you yes send it back to
you bye
she always gets the cool assignments
we'll